foreign the NHS is on its knees and it's
leading to hundreds of people dying
needlessly every week the messages
thousands came to defend Britain's
National Health Service it came ahead of
the latest strike in the sector pushing
for better pay and more investment now
this demonstration has been called by
various Healthcare unions and
campaigning bodies but behind them lies
a huge Workforce and they've been
wanting for some time that the whole
system's being underfunded leaving them
demoralized
Jordan Rivera is an occupational
therapist at a public hospital she's
been busy supporting colleagues taking
strike action and before this protest
she told Al Jazeera nobody takes the
decision lightly at the minute it feels
like that's the only way to
fight for the NHS actually
as well these are our family members who
are also impacted if if there was no NHS
there
campaigners accuse the government of
pushing people towards Private health
care and allowing the NHS to decline
that warning was taken up by U.S actor
Rob Delaney whose two-year-old son died
of a brain tumor and because of the way
that the NHS has started it
the flame the purity of what the NHS is
and how it's free at point of use and
how there is no barrier no for-profit
barrier between you and your care
we didn't spend a minute on the phone
with people from health insurance
companies saying you can't get that MRI
we don't approve that drug next week
Junior doctors who make up 40 of the
medical Workforce stage three days of
strikes they say real terms pay cuts and
increased workloads are driving people
from their profession like others family
doctors have one of the highest
professional group suicide rates because
of the stress that they're under
and then the government attacks them for
not working hard enough ambulance staff
are worried that by the time they get to
somebody who on an emergency in their
home they'll find a dead body rather
than somebody that they can look after
and Care there's a massive level of
anxiety on the back of covid where they
gave everything with the NHS a top
priority for British voters the
politicians are under pressure to commit
to saving it now and in the long term
Nadeem Barber Al Jazeera London